im rennen felsischen bernkastel kues
baut das land parallel zum burgberg
tunnel einen neuen fluchtstollen der
wird mit reichlich beton ausgespritzt
bei der berechnung der menge die dafür
nötig ist ist den bauexperten ein
peinlicher und teurer fehler passiert
denn sie haben kubikmeter mit
quadratmeter verwechselt mit
gravierenden folgen das projekt wird
eine satte million euro teurer
sowas darf nicht passieren ich kann doch
bei einer öffentlichen ausschreibung
quadratmeter geht mit kubikmeter
verwechseln
und dann wird die ganze show ja viel
teurer
das ist ein hohen hoch drei das weiß
sogar ein lehrling der im ersten jahr
ist lächerlich
dann wenn so weit da herauskommt seit
oktober 2018 wird der burgberg tunnel in
sachen sicherheit nachgerüstet kernstück
ist die neue flucht röhre
ursprünglich sollte das gesamte projekt
6,8 millionen euro kosten aber kurze
zeit später sind es schon acht millionen
denn der fels ist brüchiger als
angenommen
doch es wird noch teurer denn jetzt hat
man auch noch einen abenteuerlichen
planungsfehler entdeckt bei der
berechnung der benötigten menge beton
hat man fälschlicherweise quadratmeter
veranschlagt und nicht kubikmeter das
bedeutet es muss vielmehr beton verbaut
und bezahlt werden als geplant
dadurch wird das bauprojekt mindestens
neun millionen euro kosten von experten
würde man erwarten dass sie den
unterschied zwischen quadratmetern
kubikmeter kennen sind als experten sagt
man doch immer und fachleute ja und dann
haben wir geschlafen oder war am montag
vielleicht wo sie nicht gut drauf war
aber wer ist für die millionen fehler
verantwortlich der rheinland-pfälzische
landesbetrieb mobilität ist um
schadensbegrenzung bemüht schriftlich
heißt es dies war ein einfaches
menschliches versagen eines mitarbeiters
des vom lbm beauftragten ingenieurbüros
die qualitätskontrolle scheint hier
versagt zu haben der ärger ist
verständlich und nachvollziehbar dass
nach all den jahren planung
und vorbereitung niemand den fehler
entdeckt hat kann in bernkastel-kues
keiner glauben
denk ich mal wird ja nicht nur ein
mensch darüber gucken da werden mehrere
drüber schauen und das denn allen das
nicht aufgefallen ist das ist mehr könig
mir dürfte so was auf der arbeit oder zu
hause dürfte so etwas nicht passieren
ostern 2020 soll der burgberg tunnel
wieder eröffnet werden immer
vorausgesetzt dass es ab jetzt keine
bösen und teuren überraschungen mehr
gibt